JENNY BROWN: Last
week, it was papercuts,
and this week, it's elephants
or something like that.
Because today, on
Cloud Storage bytes,
we're talking about
large file uploads
and how you can move
mountains in mere moments.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Sometimes, you've got
very large files that just
seem to crawl during upload.
Let's say you've got a data set
with files from a few hundred
megabytes up to two
gigs, and this data set
is really giving you trouble.
If you take a peek
under the hood,
you'd notice a
slight upper limit
in terms of upload speeds.
Let's also assume you're
using the Python API,
meaning our trusty gsutil now
warns you that the file size is
too large.
If you take a closer
look at that warning,
it's making a potentially
game-changing suggestion--
use parallel composite uploads
for the best performance
when dealing with one
or more large files.
During parallel
composite uploads,
gsutil splits your larger
files into smaller pieces,
and then uploads
them in parallel,
and then composes them back
together in your GCS bucket.
It even cleans up
after itself, removing
all temporary components.
Just like what we saw
in our parallel uploads
for the smaller files,
composite uploads
dramatically improve the
performance with larger files.
On some tests, there's as
much as a two-time improvement
in the upload speeds, which
means you're well on your way
to moving that mountain.
There's more to come about
large file performance,
but we're going to save
that for another episode.
If you want to know more about
parallel composite uploads
for large files, check out
the links in the description.
And as always, don't forget
to subscribe, give us a like,
and tell us what you want
to learn about Google Cloud
Storage.
Thank you for joining us
for this quick byte of cloud
storage.
See you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]